Why Do People In Asia Use Chopsticks
Created roughly 4,000-5,000 years ago in China,
the earliest versions of something like chopsticks
were used for cooking (they’re perfect for
reaching into pots full of hot water or oil)
and were most likely made from twigs.
While it’s difficult to nail down a firm
date, it would seem it wasn’t until around
500-400 AD that they began being used as table
utensils.
One factor that contributed to this switch
was a population boom across the country.
Consequently, resources, particularly for
cooking, became incredibly scarce.
As a result, people began cutting their food
into tiny pieces so it would cook faster.
The bite sized morsels rendered table knives
obsolete, as there was very little left to
cut.
However, they were now perfect for eating
with chopsticks, which were also made from
cheap materials and easily made.
Thus, a trend was born.
The table knife’s decline in popularity
in these regions at this time can also be
attributed to the teachings of Confucius,
who was a vegetarian.
He believed that knives weren’t appropriate
to eat with.
As Confucius supposedly said,
The honourable and upright man keeps well
away from both the slaughterhouse and the
kitchen.
And he allows no knives on his table.
It was due to this that it’s believed that
Chinese chopsticks are traditionally blunt
at the tip and thus somewhat poor choices
to try to spear food as you would with a fork.
Within about a century of this, chopsticks
had migrated to other Asian countries, such
as Japan, Korea and Vietnam.
One distinct difference between Japanese and
Chinese chopsticks was that the former were
made from a single piece of bamboo that were
joined at the base.
In addition, Japanese chopsticks were originally
used solely for religious ceremonies.
Regardless of their differences, chopsticks
remained popular in both countries and are
still the primary utensil of choice.
While the early chopsticks were more often
than not made of some cheap material, such
as bamboo, later silver chopsticks were sometimes
used during Chinese dynastic times in order
to prevent food poisoning.
How?
It was believed that silver utensils would
turn black if they came into contact with
any life threatening toxins.
Unfortunately for those engaging in this practise,
silver doesn’t turn black when it touches
the likes of cyanide or arsenic, among other
poisons.
However, it most definitely can change colour
if touched by garlic, onion or rotten eggs
– all of which release hydrogen sulfide
which reacts with the silver causing it to
change colour.
For anyone that has ever had difficulty eating
rice with chopsticks, you may have wondered
why anyone would choose this particular utensil
for consuming such food with.
Perhaps one of the earliest of table utensils,
such as the spoon, would work better here.
But you see, in Asia, the majority of rice
is either a short or medium grain variety
often with starches that are particularly
gummy or clumpy.
As such, it sticks together and is quite easily
picked up by chopsticks.
In comparison, many Westerners eat long grain
rice (often highly processed) with is much
fluffier and the individual grains are more
distinct and for the unpracticed hand, difficult
to eat
with chopsticks.